you know everybody has their own vision
of heaven nirvana
i think we're here we made it i love
when these guys visit two of my favorite
restaurants two of my favorite guys in
town car mines and virgils i can tell
you as a dad either one of these places
would be a great way to spend father's
day chefs michael and gino and blank
great blake griego join us with uh some
fantastic food and you have some great
specials coming up for father's day as
well yes we do so got the virgil side we
got our tomahawk steak 28 28 ounce bone
in and then we got two grilled shrimp
skewers a lot of people would split that
right yes it's definitely enough for two
people yeah that's a lot of steak and
then you get your choice of two sides
anything that we make in-house you do
that what for 99 bucks or something 99
that's great yes and then you get a for
father's day you get a free pint of
virgil's ale all right yes that's a good
deal yes do you need to make
reservations at either place uh before
father's day especially for father's day
you can if you want but watkins are
always welcome okay at our restaurant
all right and carmine same story highly
recommended at carmine's at the forum
shops we have 850 seats but i would
definitely recommend for fallout's day
the big holidays you know to try to
pre-book us okay so we got the big steak
uh at virgil's what about carmine's for
father's day carmine's in the forum
shops we're doing a two and a half pound
fillet roast it to whatever temperature
you like roasted chipotle onions stuffed
tomatoes roasted asparagus 120 bucks you
get all your sides included with your
steak meant to be shared four to six
people that's fantastic how has it been
as as you've recovered from uh
quarantine the pandemic and everything
like that is business back to full force
oh
it's probably times ten really a lot of
people were waiting to get back out yeah
we need sixteen hundred seats at carmine
so 850 doesn't cut it for us and virgos
has 500 seats they could probably use a
thousand seats i love it that's
fantastic and do you guys do
enough barbecue to take care of
everybody all throughout the day or do
you run out sometimes no our goal is to
try to take care of everybody throughout
the day yeah never run out yes i know
some of the places roadside places will
have enough barbecue and when they're
out they're out and they close yeah we
definitely dialed in so we we make the
right amount on a daily basis what else
should people be looking for let's start
with virgils and then carmize what else
should people ask for when they get
there always our famous texas style
brisket over there
memphis style ribs and our of course our
virgil's wings
are always always great what's your
opinion on this does a good steak or
does a good brisket anything like that
need barbie's barbecue sauce absolutely
not amen brother amen all right what
about carmine's what else should people
be asking go ahead the sauce is on the
inside of all of our meats oh yeah
there's so much so tender he's smoking
24 hours a day
i mean those things don't cook in a few
minutes how long do they uh take a
brisket brisket you're looking at uh 10
to 12 hours our pork butts are 12 12 to
14 and ribs are six to eight hours and
that's why it's sacrilege sacrilege i
tell you to put barbecue sauce on these
things all right carmine's what should
people ask for um so we did battle of
the wings for father's day so virgil's
wings are smoking of course carmine's
wings italian restaurant amazing uh deep
fried tostada herb butter sauce we
brought our favorites lasagna chicken
parm
eggplant parm spaghetti meatballs
a little salad for the you know moms are
coming with the father so we definitely
got to do that so i might have a little
salad before i start you know but i'll
tell you this i don't go too much and i
i think your sides are amazing
but i think hey man let's spend the time
on the meat right you know let's not
let's not fill up too fast on that other
stuff
you guys are awesome carmine's virgils
go there father's day great place to
spend it and we're going to dig in now
mercedes because this is going to be
gone by the time you finish this next
segment the smile on your face is
priceless i love it